Hey,
what's going on is bill burr and uh,
this is the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast.
Stan.
Guys,
I'm running out of ways to say it.
All right.
I'm just going to have to go with the standard,
you know,
I always just say what's going on?
It's bill birth Monday morning podcast.
I'm just going to come up with a standard one.
You know what the fuck did I just do?
That was like a,
I got birds sitting outside on my porch now.
I'm fucking office is a fucking mess here.
Anyways,
how are you?
How's your week been going?
Well that's good.
Um,
I'd been a busy beaver wrapping up emphasis was family.
I keep bringing it up.
Uh,
we're,
we're editing episodes six,
we've locked one through four,
which means a,
I think that means no more animation.
The timing of it is locked.
You know what's fucked up.
Once you lock it,
you only way you can change a joke as if it takes,
if it's the same amount of time and basic lip movement.
Because at this point,
they're already having voice actors all over different countries doing the show
in Spanish,
French and all this other shit.
Uh,
I don't know if they're going to get it,
you know,
it's Netflix.
They're worldwide.
So I guess that's what they're doing.
So once you lock it,
I learned that because I was just like,
hey,
you know,
I dunno about that joke.
Everybody just looked at me.
I was like,
what if we write a whole paragraph is shit?
And everybody's just looking at me like,
uh,
okay.
Uh,
when they see the show with locked,
what that means is right now doing that shit to me and whatever.
I'm the fucking new guy.
I'm the new guy.
So anyways,
um,
oh,
freckles,
freckles has a back on it with the working out,
you know,
took a nice loss last week.
What did I do?
Did I hang my head?
Sure I did.
Did I take it out of my wife?
Of course.
Did I make scary faces of children walking by me on the streets?
So they cried and I felt better about myself.
Absolutely.
But once I got through that childish period,
um,
I got right back on it.
You know,
I said I was getting down to a buck 62.
I'm fucking getting down to it.
Weighed myself this morning and a,
I'm going in the right direction to turn the ship around and um,
I've almost lost 20 pounds.
You know what happens when you lose almost 20 pounds?
People stop saying you look good.
They start giving you shit.
They start trying to pick you apart.
You know,
just like the Patriots,
he went a couple of rigs.
All of a sudden you're not the Darlin's anymore.
Everybody's trying to find fault.
So people are giving me Shit,
right?
Getting Shit on Twitter,
like,
you know,
doing all this stuff about,
oh wait,
was a wood shop with your ra?
Sad percentage.
Got a bunch of those,
you know,
thinking I'm just sitting here like some chick before a wedding,
just not eating.
I'm fucking eating like a maniac.
I have breakfast,
a snack lunch than something else.
And then I have a meal at four and it's six fuel in my body.
Dude,
it's fucking bizarre.
I don't have any sugar,
salt cravings right now.
I fucking walked by the other day I was walking down the street by [inaudible]
and these people are outside while,
while,
and now we're eating pasta with bread rolls.
And I didn't give a shit.
I just looked at it like,
oh,
what the fuck is I used to eat that,
you know,
before when I was on the smack,
you know when I was drinking the booze and all that shit,
you know,
it's sugar,
salt,
sugar,
salt.
I would look at that pass to got o don't fucking cancel everything.
Let's sit down and fucking put that man hole in my stomach.
Um,
it was the thing too.
I'm not being some can't right now cause I know most of you guys who are junkies
right now,
sugar,
salt,
doing that fucking thing.
I understand you don't think I'm going to be back
fucking limp in my way back into regular person rehab with the sugar salt
course.
I will.
But right now I got to fucking see this thing through.
So,
uh,
Oh God,
the blandness of some of this shit that I'm eating
know my four o'clock meal is I make Turkey patties.
You know,
if I treat myself and I got enough fucking cha call,
I'll throw on my little Hibachi,
right.
And uh,
I don't know,
people around the country call them Hibachi.
It's just like a little grill.
I remember I said a bace the first time we move out to la,
the first time I was out here in the late nineties,
people like I got to La as I,
you know,
they do that thing.
If she had sketch on fucking,
uh,
SNL,
the Californians where they wouldn't say a word and they wouldn't close their
mouth until the end of it.
Like the,
we live in cow law class.
Um,
there is something about people that live out in Calabasas and in that fucking
area.
Um,
I had to go to the doctor the other day,
you know,
I'm an old man getting a checkup or whatever.
So this lady fucking brings me into this room and starts doing something to my
leg.
I got like this little varicose vein.
I'm trying to get rid of,
she's taken in with this fucking laser thing and I found out x cause I got like
low Brugge blood pressure.
So the,
my heart shoots it down to my feet,
but then it doesn't come back up my legs the way it should.
It tells me I get to wear compression socks and shit.
Fuck it.
Looking at him like I'm that fucking old,
you know when you fly on planes where some compression socks.
So anyways,
this person,
she takes me into the fucking room,
right?
And I go,
uh,
I was going like,
what to have,
I had my bag and my bag with me and I just,
there was a chair,
you know,
the fucking classic,
share that has the wheels on it that the fucking practitioner always sits in.
So it's all the way in the corner.
And if I set my bag down with my sneakers,
it's the bag and the sneakers and now in the way of the chair.
So I say to the person,
I'm like,
do you need that chair?
And she's like,
Nah.
So I set the shit down.
And then she,
then I sit down and she's like,
oh wait,
I do need it.
And she just starts dragging it across the floor.
My sneakers are underneath it,
like,
like beginning to turn over and over and over,
like rolling along with it.
And I'm just looking at it,
I just like fucking pick the chair up and give it to her.
And then I joked,
I'm like,
are you better with the laser then you are with the chairs of that.
I ask,
I'm like,
why
I am a law?
Are you saying I know,
I'm sorry.
It's really weird.
I must say she was dumb.
They just did that accent.
Ah.
Say I asked how the,
the going to what I call,
uh,
see me downstairs and the other what?
Raw Rum.
Yeah.
I,
I've been having a lot of that this week.
I was,
um,
I was fucking sitting at home,
right.
And,
uh,
I've been dying to make a fucking key lime pie.
I love key lime pie and key limes are in season.
So I learned from last year that she can't go to fucking snooty white people
grocery stores because for whatever reason they got something against key lime.
She come in and you're like,
do you guys have key limes to like key lime pie?
No key lines.
Like the Pie?
No.
Like the fucking lines tell her to stay while you're yelling.
The all I have is the pie.
They won't fucking sell them.
But if you go to a grocery store,
we're enough.
I Dunno if it's Asian or Latino people.
I don't know what it is out here.
If you go to Johns j o n s they have them.
If you go to like trader,
jazz and far our fucking a whole food,
they don't have them.
Gimme like the Pie.
No,
the fucking line.
Um,
so anyways,
so I went down,
I got those fucking things and I'm like,
all right,
I'm gonna try and make one of these things as I'm sitting here at dieting,
I,
you know,
what the fuck,
what am I gonna do so I can fucking eat Turkey patties and salary for rest of my
life.
I have been since the 4th of July,
so I'm
okay.
I ended up getting these things.
I made this fucking pie and a homemade whipped cream,
which is not difficult by the way.
I know made homemade whipped cream.
Do you know you just take heavy cream,
one of those little fucking things like metals,
little cartons of milk you'd get when you were a kid going to school.
You just pour that into a ball and then like a quarter cup of sugar and I don't
think it's that much.
You,
I've put some sugar in there and then you just put your uh,
like an egg beater.
He just put it on high and all of a sudden it turns into the old fucking whipped
cream.
If you go too long somehow,
I don't know,
it turns in dope,
but then you've got sugar in it,
so it tastes weird.
I think it's more like the consistency.
If you put salt in,
if you've got to make butter,
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking about Bonita.
Anyways,
so I made the thing with a Graham cracker crust.
Um,
the hardest part was,
was juice in the fucking lives.
Um,
there's little fuckers,
man.
They didn't want to,
I though the lady,
the lady I was watching on Youtube,
she actually got one of those garlic press things,
a bigger one,
she'd have them.
And so I put it in there and uh,
I got to tell you,
man,
I think it was taught as a motherfucker.
I don't know if I didn't make it right,
I'm going to back off the lime juice.
Uh,
I actually put a little extra lime juice in because usually people,
they,
they under fucking season I find.
So I just assumed that this lady,
you know,
who cooks for a living,
didn't know what she was doing.
And I'm a fucking standup comedian.
So yeah,
by all means,
Bill.
Overruled.
The chef.
Um,
but are you really a chef if you just making youtube videos?
Okay.
That's like me.
I do a podcast.
Anybody can do this,
you know,
do I really consider myself a broadcaster?
I don't,
I consider myself a jerk off talking into a microphone that I then upload onto
my computer.
Um,
so anyways,
so I tried it man.
It taught as a motherfucker too much in as much lime juices.
It was then they had the,
the,
the rind over the Rhine,
whatever the fuck you say the skin of it's sprinkled on top and I was too much,
too much,
but I'm going to finish it.
I'm not going to lie to you.
Uh,
but somehow I'm still fucking a,
I'm still dropping weight.
I got to see this thing through.
I got to see it fucking thrilled cause uh,
I'm finally,
it took me whatever I'm into right now,
eight weeks.
It took me eight weeks just to have hope that I could actually have a decent
fucking torso again.
It was fun.
I'll tell you it was rough.
You know,
I'm,
I'm telling you man,
a button down shirt is a middle aged man's friend.
Okay.
And if you need a Snuggie,
you just put on a fucking sport coat and all of a sudden magically you're in
shape and a nice,
like I said,
then one day you got to go to the company picnic and all of a sudden it's t
shirt time.
Remember that from the fucking and Italian show there on the beach in Jersey.
It's a short time and you fucking show up,
you know,
with fucking love handles
the size of a fucking loaf of bread.
Um,
so anyways,
I've been having a lot of that miscommunication shit going on this week,
right?
So I,
I know I was going to tell you the key line story.
So I go down to Johns j o n s not a pause,
three,
not possessive.
John's,
I go down there,
uh,
that wouldn't be wants,
what did,
that'd be Jua in us.
It's John's whatever.
So I go down there and I'm all excited.
They got these fucking things and they got him in space.
Big fucking pile of them.
And um,
so I go down and you know,
I got like a pound of them,
whatever.
I've got a little more than a pound just in case I didn't have enough juice or
So I'm all excited.
I'm going to make this fucking pie right.
So I'm standing in line now I'm that do,
she was just in a great mood talking to strangers.
So I'm standing there waiting to pay and I see this lady and I'm all excited
cause I would make the pie.
And she had this really weird looking bread,
but it looked delicious.
So I just say to her,
I'm like,
Oh,
what is that?
Is that,
is that bread?
You've got bread there?
And she just looks at me and she goes,
what?
I realized she barely spoke English.
And then I just said,
uh,
I always said,
I said,
okay,
well what kind of bread is that?
Oh,
it's delicious.
And She just goes,
what?
And then I totally just switched and I was like,
is that bread?
And she just goes,
yes.
Just turned around away from where it did.
That thing where you're laughing and try not to move your head.
The whole conversation just went south.
Um,
so anyways,
anyways,
how'd your week go and Huh?
You hanging in there?
Hot as a motherfucker out here.
Goddamn.
Uh,
Los Angeles,
where I'm living in a,
I've been,
as I've been telling you guys,
I'm going to work on my way through this Andre Agassi book.
Not like it's been work.
This book opens fucking great.
I just been so damn busy and uh,
it's unreal.
Jesus Christ,
as he take us through the Brooke Shields relationship,
you know,
he takes a little heat himself,
but a woo.
He does not pull any punches,
man.
He's not being like mean.
He's just fucking state and easy.
This dude's just putting it out there,
like every great book should,
um,
talked about doing crystal meth.
It was like,
I had no idea he did that,
but just the way he,
the way he's taking you through the bookshields shields relationship is the same
way he takes,
he takes you to his matches and you're rooting for the guy yet had stomach's in
knots.
As you're reading it,
you're like,
come on,
come on.
Oh good.
He's to the sammies through the 70s.
And then he's like,
and then my mind starts fucking with me.
And you're like,
God,
it's like you're winning and losing with them.
It's such a great fucking book.
So it ended up making me a curious as to like the,
the tennis tour,
which I've never paid attention to.
Like most like passive tennis fans.
I just watched the majors and for the most part I just watched Wimbledon.
I always watch Wimbledon.
I could give a fuck about the Australian Open US Open every once in a while I
would watch,
but it was all about breakfast at Wimbledon.
I grew up watching that.
I don't know why I thought the grass was cool and whatever.
Roland Garros to clay just bored me.
I don't know why.
Now I'm totally into all of it.
So it made reading this book made me want to look up the tour to see how many
there are.
So I believe that 62 events every year and for hardcore sports fans,
this what actually this will probably interest you as far as like how they get
their rankings.
I might be off on this.
It obviously has to do with the major events that you,
when you get points for it.
And then also I would also think like who you beat would also have something to
do with it.
Like if you will ranked 100th and all of a sudden you're fucking beat the number
one person in the world.
I don't give a fuck how many points you have.
They got a movie up at least 50,
60 spots,
right?
Or whatever.
I'm just using that as a rough example.
So here's,
here's how the point system works.
There's,
um,
there's uh,
sorry,
um,
for a grand slam you get 2000 points and then underneath that,
then there's four grand slams,
Australia,
French,
uh,
the English,
Wimbledon and a,
the u s open.
So all of those are worth 2000 if you win them.
And then they have these other ones that are worth a thousand.
They call him the gold something or other.
And for some reason they were in gold.
And I read a couple of blogs and tennis people don't quite understand why,
look why they're called that.
It says,
uh,
their ATP World Tour Masters,
um,
events and those are worth a thousand and there's nine of those.
So for nobody,
and by the way,
nobody has ever won all nine of those,
which I found really interesting.
Like A,
there's a couple people in doubles have won them.
Um,
and like Djokovich has one eight,
I think [inaudible] seven or eight of them.
Um,
so whatever.
And they're basically,
and while I was psyched,
there's one out here in Indian Wells,
um,
they're basically,
I went and I fucking read them the for you.
Um,
okay,
well let me get through the whole thing.
And then there's events that are worth 500 points and then there's ones that are
just worth 250 points,
which are just shit bum fuck in lowest,
like you're barely on the God damn tour.
Um,
so I think these pros,
the upper echelon ones,
you know,
if they're,
if they're coming back from an injury,
they'll probably play it at two 50 or a if they're just trying to get some sort
of points and they just need them or they need the money and they fucked up and
bought too many God damn rackets that whatever the fuck they do way he would,
he publicly rackets for free when you,
anyways,
um,
I just find it really interesting.
So there's nine of these,
these events,
I'm not going to bore you with the 502 50.
Read all 62.
The first one's in March,
that's Indian wells out here in California.
And then the next one is in Miami.
So what's cool is you can lose the Australian Open,
but then when both of those and a thousand a piece and it's like you want to May
gea,
then there's one in Monte Carlo
that's fucking great.
And I'm like,
why isn't it say in uh,
France?
I forgot.
That's a sovereign state Monaco,
which means they're their own little country.
It's funny why nobody just attacks him.
There's so little.
Um,
maybe because they're all in the aluminum.
All right.
Um,
then there's one in Spain,
in Madrid.
There's one in Rome,
Italy.
Both of those are in May.
So these are people who've passive tennis fans.
It might be a thousand point point or right down the street and you'll see
Serena or Federer Djokovich or whatever.
There's one in Canada and Montreal that's in,
uh,
August.
Well,
I guess you guys would go to the website.
The one I just watched in Cincinnati,
I saw Serena when that one,
Cincinnati,
who would've thought,
no,
there's one in Shanghai.
This is worth a thousand points.
And then the last one is in Paris.
I was fucking French constantly.
Got One in Monaco,
1,001 in Paris for a thousand and then they have Roland Garros with 2000
okay.
Sons of bitches.
Um,
and there's some sort of Barclays,
whatever.
I thought it was really interesting.
So I'm going to try to pay attention.
One of that shit.
It kind of helps you get through the summer.
I just need help through July,
mid June into July.
And then I get excited because football's coming back and then by the end of
August I start watching baseball.
Like today I was driving around in my old truck and I was listening to the
Dodgers playing an afternoon game against Cincinnati and I'm embarrassed to say,
I don't know anybody's name at all in baseball.
The only people I know is when I stopped paying attention five years ago when
they said big papi tested positive for something.
I was just like,
ah dude,
I don't know.
I don't want to watch Santa Claus go down to,
you know,
nothing ever came of it.
But yeah,
it was just baseball was,
it was just coming out of that roid era where it was just like,
all right,
I'm so sick of you guys telling me something that I cheered for eight years ago
now doesn't count.
Just fucking clean it up.
And I,
I think they cleaned,
I dunno.
I don't even give a shit whether they did or not.
I don't understand why they can't use steroids.
These fucking poor bastards.
They can,
if you read the beginning of this Agassi book,
the fucking pain that this guy is in,
just trying to get out of bed,
just trying to to stand upright and then having to take an hour long shower and
then go get shot up with cortisone is stuff and get out on the court and get
himself all warmed up so his body can actually function.
These guys,
anything you can give these guys,
men and women,
they,
they should be fucking legal.
It make for,
I don't know,
their bodies would,
he'll quit.
I don't what the fuck though.
You're not a doctor.
I mean it's,
it appears to me as a comedian that with no medical background that their bodies
would heal.
Okay.
They'd be healthier,
you'd have better matches,
they could enjoy themselves more.
I mean,
what the fuck,
how much pain do they got to go through?
Why can they do roads?
Um,
anyway,
so let's,
uh,
let's plot,
you know what?
I got to read a little bit ab one,
one little advertising thing.
One,
one is the loneliest advertising that I ever read was that three dog night.
It's funny,
I drink the two dogs special at the juice bar.
All right,
next issue.
Oh,
we got three here.
All right.
Oh,
by the way,
you know,
somebody I t a d d all over the place.
Somebody sent me something really cool word.
Uh,
I was talking about,
you know,
one of my favorite drum records of all time is Jane's Addiction.
Now our ritual de la de la habitual over the fuck you say.
It's one of my favorite drum records of all time.
And uh,
somebody just sent me something called the,
uh,
I don't know the name of the band.
Is the wedding present and the name of the album,
sea monster sea monsters.
Now I don't know if this person's just fucking with me or whatever,
but uh,
yeah,
if you guys have favorite drum records or whatever,
base records,
get tar records,
anything,
let me know what they are.
Cause uh,
I will download that shit and have a listen to it.
And I was just singing.
Three is a magic number.
You guys don't schoolhouse rock some of this sickest fucking session drummers.
Uh,
musicians play on that thing.
Listen to three is a magic number.
And listen to the fucking drums.
Listen to how fucking
the tasty licks the guy had groove in his fucking ass off,
but not overplay it.
Plate perfect for the sock.
I want to listen to her right now.
It's fucking amazing.
Um,
those are,
those are some of my favorite fucking musicians.
Are those people that just back up somebody and are absolutely fucking killing
it.
And then they just walk away and you have no fucking Clint Eastwood in those
cowboy movies.
He never had a name.
Right.
Fucking ass.
Anyways,
let me,
yeah,
let's read here.
All right,
next issue.
Everybody,
your time is precious and you want to feed your mind with the best of what's out
there.
Don't you hate when somebody speaks for you?
Okay.
Uh,
but who has time to sift through all this nonsense on the Internet?
For those of us who want premium content and don't have time to waste finding
it,
there's next issue.
Next issue was the mobile app that lets you tap directly into the world's most
popular magazines.
Anytime,
anywhere using your phone or tablet,
they've got all your favorites,
like sports illustrated,
Maximin,
Esquire,
and next issue lets you dive deeper into the story with interactive content not
available anywhere else,
giving you a richer reading experience.
Why do I need to interact with it?
Why don't you write a fucking story worthy that I don't have to have scratch and
sniff?
I've never felt that reading sports illustrated like,
Oh God,
if I could just smell the mound anyways as sign up for next issue.
Right now you'll get immediate access to all these top magazines including back
issues and exclusive videos and photos.
Oh,
there you go.
The videos and photos.
I'm sorry.
Next issue.
Once again,
you were right.
Again,
you can try next issue for free right now.
When you go to next issue.com/burr if you guys are wondering why I go free,
they got this guy out here.
I don't know if they have it around the country.
He's a mattress dude.
Fucking do something or your mattress is free.
I got to give him a shout out.
Okay.
What the fuck's in Aa?
When I was in Massachusetts,
it was Jordan's furniture.
Jordan's furniture wall.
Fam left dodge.
Back Brook,
right.
Or Daniel Webster.
Um,
they had that and then they had the light and leisure,
the purple building.
And this guy was trying to do the crazy yeti thing and every time he came on he,
it was,
he was the crazy guy who sold lamps and his thing every time was like,
God,
I really did this time.
Oh,
I shit,
why did I order so many labs?
Okay.
Ah,
fuck.
I gotta get ready.
Thanks man.
Every fucking time.
It's just like,
dude,
why don't you just look around your store and take a little inventory?
Uh,
the bottom line is a,
you weren't given us a fucking
okay
a break on the price.
You were just acting like you were crazy.
And for some reason people let you run a store.
All right.
Zip Recruiter,
uh,
business owners.
Did you know that summer's a great time to hire the best people with your
competent?
What'd you competitors on vacation?
There's less competition for quality candidates,
but posting your job in one place isn't enough to find them.
And when you short staff,
there's no time to deal with dozens of different jobs sites.
You don't need that shit.
There was nothing you could do about it though.
Until now,
thanks to zip recruiter.com you can post to 100 plus job sites with a single
click a just post once and within 24 hours,
watch your candidates roll into ZipRecruiter's.
Easy to use interface plus be instantly matched to candidates from,
from over 4 million resumes.
Zip recruiter
has been used by over 400,000 businesses and you could try it right now for
absolutely free.
Try ZipRecruiter and get you PR.
Get your perfect candidate this summer before they go to somebody else today.
You can try ZipRecruiter for free.
Go to ziprecruiter.com/burr that's ziprecruiter.com/bar
ziprecruiter.com/burr all right,
the last one,
mercifully no more bill reading out loud.
Oh,
it's time for fucking,
Oh
hey,
you like making great money,
right?
This is red.
Like I'm fucking calling you from an alley.
Hey,
you like making great money,
right?
He's a cool opportunity I had to share with you.
Okay.
Looking both ways.
Driving with Uber,
Uber's that popular smart phone app that connects right is with drivers.
A lot of people take Uber all the time.
A lot of people love them by the way,
and they just loved chatting with the different drivers and evidently some of
them have really interesting stories to why they drive with Uber.
I always though scientists evolution,
they love being there.
That's actually a taxi driver.
A would've stripped thought I didn't want to do that.
I don't know.
John,
I've had for cards out license come.
They love being their own boss.
They earn great money.
It's easy to start.
You just need a car and a license.
Driving with Uber is great for anyone who needs flexibility.
This is one of the great jobs of all time because they seem to just hire you,
right?
So you know,
if he got a guitar and you want a better guitar,
just start driving people around.
You know
what a better drum kit.
I mean,
I will use this students,
you can make some extra money between classes.
Now's the prime time to cash in driving with Uber.
You'll thank me for telling you how to get paid every week.
I could be getting into your car when you drive with Uber.
Well,
I'll tell you right now,
I won't be sober.
That's for,
that's the only time I take Uber because I'm responsible when I drink.
You got a car and a license.
Put them both to work,
uh,
for you and start earning serious life changing money today.
Sign up and drive with Uber.
Visit drive with uber.com that's drive with uber.com eh?
Yeah.
Drive with uber.com.
They just feel like you don't hear it for the first two times.
Do they?
Um,
one,
if that works in your relationship,
bill wants a blow job.
That's bell once a blow job.
Hey though wants a blow job.
Why did she say after he ties?
Um,
all right.
Okay.
He's a good line.
I used on my wife the other day.
I was like,
sweetie,
what are you going to be sick of being sick of me?
She actually laughed and said,
sorry,
I'm an asshole.
I'm not easy to live with.
All right,
let's um,
okay,
what the fuck am I here?
What I want to talk about.
Oh,
by the way,
um,
I actually reached out to the nerds on Twitter.
Yeah.
Seeing if there was any way to,
I saw it.
All of a sudden I have this,
I watch APP.
Like I had a really bad week with my iPhone.
All of a sudden it was just wigging out on me
and um,
I ended up,
you know,
I couldn't get messages.
I had to keep shutting them down.
I couldn't read my messages,
I couldn't close apps,
all this stuff.
The whole thing was going haywire and I was thinking,
did I fucking spill water on this thing?
What's going on?
And then somebody,
uh,
over atF is for family families like,
well you have you downloaded the new operating system.
I'm like,
I never do that.
It just fills up your phone.
That's how I was able to keep the iPhone for us for fucking
right.
I was able to keep it forever cause I never downloaded any of the new shit.
The phone was more than good enough when it was just the three.
Okay.
I have no fun.
I would still use a rotary phone with the phone cord.
I don't give a fuck these Goddamn I flew,
I found it like a,
a second one to star trek.
I don't need the new one.
So inadvertently by not needing it and not wanting it,
I was able to keep these phones for fucking years until they finally just died.
Um,
but now these fucking apple con,
I guess they figured it out probably cause idiots like me running the Yap about
it on podcasts,
uh,
are new operating system now you like half the downloaded as far as,
and maybe I'm wrong,
I'm reaching out to the nerds here.
All right.
Is that what's going on here now?
Like they make,
they're forcing you to download the new thing so you fill it up.
So when the iPhone six s or fucking seven comes out,
I have to go get it.
Cause if that's the case,
I'm out.
Cause now I downloaded it.
Now we have the Iwatch APP.
I don't have an Iwatch.
And you know what?
Nobody has a fucking Iwatch.
Have you seen anybody that thing fucking bombed?
And I love it.
I love it.
But you know,
I probably for the environment,
it's probably not a good fucking thing because they'll just dump them in the
ocean.
You know what I mean?
Oh,
they'll feed the cows and then you're fucking,
they'll sell them to farmers and they'll feed them the cows and then there'll be
in your burgers or some shit.
Who the fuck knows but it is cause I've always been that guy like,
dude,
we got enough technology.
We're fine.
We're good.
It's too good.
It's too much.
It's too much shit.
We were good right around 95 94 95 was fine.
You know what I mean?
Fine.
Everything's fine.
Okay.
And they'll put the new shit cause then you got to throw out the old shit.
It ends up in the ocean enough or our our upgrade.
Just upgrade my fucking phone.
What do I got to go into a new one and then trade that fucker.
Man.
I hate it and I also don't like how they're gradually forcing me where I don't
have a choice on what the fuck is on my phone because eventually they're going
to force you to use iCloud,
which is so fucking intrusive that these cons want to see my pictures.
Am I fucking music and all you fucking dope out there who just like what do you
really think that taking the time,
hello,
you've hung adventure.
It did.
Did did that,
I can't even speak here.
All of that shit that I said about going into cvs and they're fucking doing
those little savings,
save scan card.
By the way,
I was 100% right about that.
They were taking information from you.
Now they tried to scan your fucking driver's license.
Just say no to those people.
I went to the doctor's office,
they go stand over here.
I'm like,
what are you doing?
They go,
well,
we're going to take a picture of you.
I go for what?
They could just share files so we can put a face to the,
it's like we get the fuck away from me.
You creep.
And I was like,
no,
I don't want you to do that.
They're like,
you don't want us to do that?
I'm like,
yes,
I don't want you to do that.
And then they go,
oh,
okay.
They try to make it seem like you have to do it.
You know what I mean?
I got to fucking varicose vein.
Who to see my fucking face.
You'd do.
She got my fucking driver's license.
And you got,
you got my,
my,
uh,
my credit card.
Well,
what's wrong with you guys?
Everybody's trying to do that.
Cause it's,
it's a new way to make money is what they do is,
is they get in from personal information about you beyond what you're there for
and beyond really in reality what they need.
And then they stock pilot and then they sell it to other people and they make
money off of your information.
And I believe that you should have to ask for that person's consent.
And then once they give consent,
that person should get a cut or percentage of the selling of their own personal
information.
Shouldn't they?
My nuts.
Like if there's money to be made,
no one about what kind of fucking fruit loops or special K on meeting,
why shouldn't I get a cut?
It's my information.
I mean,
look,
if you want to sit up there with a pad and Pencil and see me come walking in a
freckle guy just got some fucking shredded wheat.
I don't know what I'm saying.
Whatever I'm out of my fucking mind.
Don't listen to me.
Anyway,
send me your favorite drum records.
This is the,
uh,
Thursday afternoon,
Monday morning.
Just before Thursday,
Thursday afternoon,
Monday morning.
Puck has just before Friday's,
I always say just checking in on you.
You know,
the weekend's coming,
everybody,
the weekend is coming.
Hey,
by the way,
that fucking,
I,
I've said this before,
I'm gonna tell you to get that fucking men's health grip strength workout that
Bert Kreischer uh,
tweeted at me.
I have to retweet that thing.
Um,
it's,
that shit is the real deal.
I'm on the third exercise with this is the one where you just hang by one arm
with all your body weight.
You just hanging there from a fucking chin up bar Chinet pull up bar and a,
you try to work yourself up to being able to do it for a minute.
I'm up to 25 seconds with the right hand,
20 seconds with the left hand.
And,
um,
I went over to this,
uh,
the place where we were writing,
editing the show and they have this little mini gym and they had a peg board
there and I'm fucking,
I was fucking horrible with the peg board and I was like,
you know,
I've been doing this grip strength thing,
climbing the rope and shit,
let me see what I'm doing here.
And I was able to at 47 to go all the way up the pegboard and then come back
down.
I didn't try to go,
you're supposed to go up,
go over and come down.
And I wasn't able to do that.
So,
uh,
I'm fucking psyched man.
That's like,
um,
I dunno.
I know you youngsters can probably do it,
you know,
after a night of fucking booze and,
but when you're 47 that,
you know,
it makes you still feel like you matter.
Ah,
Jesus Christ.
What a fucking sad sack I am.
All right.
Um,
that's it.
Thank you guys for listening and have a wonderful weekend.
You constant.
I'll talk to you on Monday.
Yes.
All right.
There's a lot of question out there about,
you know,
things that happen within society,
specialty,
you know,
this,
this is something that I think a lot of white people need because not because
we're more racist than anybody else,
we just get just the,
the consequences of us fucking up is so much harsher than other people because,
uh,
you know,
we are the gold standard when it comes to racist.
We are in the driver's seat right now.
We have been in the driver's seat for awhile.
Basically.
Meaning that if we are ignorant ass holes,
it has way more effect than when other people are.
You know,
back in the day when other people were running shit,
that's the thing.
Whoever's on top,
if you think an ignorant,
uh,
that's what,
that's why,
you know,
if you're on top and you're thinking ignorant shit,
you have to be called on it because,
uh,
just cause he cause the effect that you can have.
You know what a mean.
Okay.
Like if somebody from Bangladesh fucking hates me,
that's such a stupid example.
Okay.
That,
that's not a race of people.
I don't even know what Bangladesh's and I gotta be honest with you.
I don't even know if that's a city or a country.
Bangladesh have ever seen that on a the prices,
right?
Yeah.
I to showcase showdown was selling yet a Bangladesh and some white trash person
like myself,
sit,
sit with a confused look on their face.
Like I don't know where that is.
Is that where the terrorists are?
I don't want to go there.
Whatever,
like a Filipino people fucking hate me.
That doesn't affect my life.
It doesn't,
I'm not going to go into a job interview at,
at,
you know,
Walmart is not run by Filipinos.
You know what I mean?
You know,
not saying there's anything wrong.
Filipinos.
Alright.
See,
we'll see what I have to do with those white person.
Let's say I'm saying I feel bad about bill paid off because we clear him on,
I have never had issues.
I got to have a lab of cafe.
Well fucking all that shit.
You got to go on the Jerry Lewis voice there lady.
Um,
so yeah,
people have questions.
So here we go.
And I think all racist should shy men.
The questions that you have,
if you have feelings about a different race of people and you just think you're
thinking something funny,
there's nothing malicious,
but is this offensive?
Is it racist?
This is,
this is the new topic.
Okay.
And if you feel that I answer these questions like the ignorant white man that I
am,
call me out on it.
I'm here.
So here we go.
This first one bill,
is it racist to call Indians?
Dibble dabbles.
And I'm talking about the Asian ones,
not native Americans.
Um,
I'm guessing by Debbie.
Deb was,
you mean Buba Dabo.
Oh,
dupe it though.
But the baby the,
but you're saying like that debit Dabu um,
is it racist?
Probably,
but it's fucking funny.
So that knocks it down a little bit.
This is what I feel that makes something like racist.
It's like,
like the reason why,
uh,
that one isn't as offensive is because we haven't,
we never enslaved them.
That's the reason why white and black shit is so sensitive is because of the
shift that we did to him.
But we haven't really fuck with those people,
you know?
So
if the black version of that was,
is it,
is it offensive to black people?
Hey man,
mother fucker or whatever.
Yes.
That would be offensive if you did some sort of marking of the way they spoke.
That would be,
that would be offensive if some CEO was giving a speech and I was driving,
uh,
actually I was having someone else drive my town car and we drove by a group of
a young mother fuckers and uh,
they proceeded to walk forwards again,
you'd have to apologize.
So I guess,
yeah,
I guess technically Duma Dabo like that would be,
that would be offensive.
Is it racist?
Um,
this is what I,
I really,
it's hard for me to say because it had,
it's what's in your heart,
you know,
cause I make fuck I really,
I make fun of everybody,
you know,
I mean,
I play a game out here,
uh,
when someone is make,
let me ask you,
I've got a question for you.
Is this racist?
I have a game out here when I ride around with Nia and she does not approve of
this to keep her in the clear,
she does not approve this.
When somebody makes a more chronic move in front of me,
you know,
driving,
you know just makes a fucking horrific move.
I play a game called old or Asian
and you have to guess,
wait cause I'm going to pass the person cause I got to see what they look like.
You know,
whenever somebody does something fucked up,
some comedians do a great joke about that.
You just want to see what the fuck they look like.
Right.
Uh,
that's the game.
Older Asian.
So as I speed up my little hybrid to try to pull parallel to them,
I always say,
what are you saying?
Yeah,
what are you going with all duration?
What do you got?
Older Asian.
She goes,
I'm not playing this game.
That's mean.
And then I was gone.
I'm going to go with old and then I pull up,
it's fucking Asian,
you know?
Or Oh I nailed it.
It was an old guy.
So is that racist?
I'm sure it's offensive,
but within the context of my own car,
you know,
I'm not yelling at anybody and I got to admit,
there's a lot of truth in the fucking game.
Yeah.
Jesus,
I'm going to have to apologize next week on the podcast.
So I would say that,
uh,
Indian people,
why don't you chime in?
I would say that,
yeah.
That they would find that they would find that offensive.
Um,
is it racist?
Let me see if I can use it in a sentence here.
Hey,
uh,
you know,
I called up customer service and,
uh,
you know,
one of those Buba Dub was answered and tried to tell me that his name was Steve
and act like he was in Tucky.
But I,
I know that he was actually an India because what he talked,
he was go with [inaudible] woods.
How can I help you?
Um,
is it racist?
Probably.
You know what,
something bad has to happen between white culture and,
uh,
or,
or western culture in a Indians.
So,
you know what I mean?
It's like a,
it's like you're playing a team and there's no rivalry.
Like patriots verse jets this year was like a whites and blacks.
It was bad.
It was a lot of hate,
you know,
but like patriots verse like the Fucking Lions,
you know?
Yeah.
There's gotta be some shit targets.
It's knocked out,
but it still hurts if somebody says something mean.
I don't,
I really don't.
What the fuck I'm talking about?
All right,
let's move to the next one.
The next one on the new controversial topic on the Monday morning podcast.
Is it racist?
All right,
here we go.
Um,
Bill,
I had an interesting experience today apparently involving me as a racist.
I was walking with two of my coworkers who are both black.
Oh Geez.
Here we go.
Um,
we were going to go get some lunch.
One of my coworkers who are most of friends with,
uh,
did a little high five fist bump shuffle with one of the female sex security
guards at the front desk.
Knowing both of them and how they interact with one another.
I kind of made a in passing comment to the tune of man,
you guys in your handshakes while obviously laughing,
laughing while obviously laughing at just how choreographed it was in more or
less picturing them in a studio or something,
working out the logistics to get the fucking handshake.
Perfect.
Anyways,
we all laughed and moved on and we got our lunch.
All right,
so nothing wrong yet.
So you're cool with these people.
You made a joke and everybody laughed.
No problems,
no problems so far.
Um,
however,
after coming back through secure,
uh,
back through security,
I noticed the security guard stopped me and Kinda had a scowl on her face.
I thought she was mad at me for something,
but it turned out she was mad at this other lady who was black because she
overheard my comment and was telling,
uh,
that security guard that she couldn't believe I had the nerve to say something
like that.
And I should be ashamed also to the point where she could,
um,
almost to the point where she could actually go complain to the human resource
people because she was offended,
um,
et Cetera,
without even considering that.
Maybe just maybe I was talking about the security guard and my coworker and not
all black people now.
It being corporate America in all I'm sure rather than even face the pos
possibility of any bad press,
they'd rather just sweep me out the door and completely ruined my re any
reputation I may or may not hold at the company just to save their own asses.
I feel I did nothing wrong and had no intentions of ever doing anything wrong.
Anything wrong,
I'm not going to go on and on about how I kiss black babies and trying to
rehabilitate inner city schools because I don't,
but I'm certainly not some corn fed rebel flag waving ignorant product of what
might be incest.
I guess my question is do we really have to walk on eggshells when we're just
making casual conversation that just any that just any client can pick apart,
select the context that they might think it is in and then start crying foul.
Basically.
I would have liked to call that woman a cunt and told her to go fuck herself.
But let's just say I was already kind of worried about my job.
All right,
let's see.
Um,
yeah,
I think this is,
this is the classic one where you were fucking around the other two people knew
you were fucking round,
but then one person decides to get offended and then you have to go on TV and
apologize.
Which personally I think is the wrong move because when you apologize now it's
like you're,
you're admitting that you meant it in a bad way.
I mean,
the apology,
I would do that and say,
look,
you know,
I'm sorry that you didn't understand that I was joking,
but I'm not going to sit here and apologize like I have any sort of ill will
come in your way,
you know,
but I,
but just to avoid the problem in the future,
uh,
white people do not use the expression you guys or you people
when talking about black people,
that's just it.
It's just not going to,
you're,
you're setting yourself up for someone to get offended.
And,
um,
there's a weird sort of a push poll going on with that whole law.
You guys and you people thing where,
um,
when somebody white says that there becomes this concern of,
that you're separating.
You're separating like,
yeah,
you know,
you people over there with how you live your lives and where over here,
black people have that weird relationship with white people where they're like,
you know,
can you stop stealing our fucking music and our culture?
Uh,
but then like if something,
you know,
hey,
let's pay the streets,
you know,
well,
make sure you do it in our neighborhood.
We're all in this together,
right.
All of us together.
You know what I mean?
So it's that weird sort of fucking push pull thing going on.
So yeah,
just avoid,
uh,
avoid the whole fucking,
um,
yeah,
you fucked up.
You didn't fuck up,
but you,
you left yourself open for a sucker punch by saying,
you guys
okay.
You know,
uh,
that's,
I guess that that's what it is.
I don't know.
That's,
that's,
that's my,
I basically a white guy telling a white guy how he fucked up.
So black people feel listening to this thing.
Uh,
please,
please help me out here.
Did I basically get it right?
Is that essentially it?
And I know most people wouldn't get offended if,
all right,
so there you go.
That's the new,
that's the new topic.
Is it racist?
And I would love to hear,
um,
some honest comments from a non white people about their thoughts.
You know,
the fucked up ones too.
Okay.
Cause I've watched enough spike Lee movies to think that evidently it's just us.
But I've hung around enough people from different races to realize,
oh yeah,
but he's like,
no,
I like to play a little game
well to your Asian or old person driving game,
except my game involves in the evening news,
it's called beaner black guy or crazy ass cracker.
Just to clarify,
I am Hispanic parentheses,
Latino,
Mexican or whatever other dumb ass term someone has come up with.
So saying beaner is okay,
see now this is why I wanted to do this segment.
This is the exact fucking reason.
Okay.
He says beaner black and cracker.
All right.
And he goes,
I could save baner because I'm Mexican.
Well there,
why can you say cracker ass cracker,
right?
It's cause I'm white and no one gives a fuck about that one.
See what I'm saying?
This is something that I learned from doing stand up in front of all different
kinds of people.
That's what I learned.
I learned that everybody basically,
it's not that they're selfish,
they just,
they look out of their own head.
You can't help but do that.
So you just see shit from your own perspective.
Like one night I was doing this kick right down at the old Boston Comedy Club in
New York City.
And one of the acts that was going up was this,
uh,
was this,
I think I told this story before,
it was a,
it was a comedy team as this Asian Guy and girl.
And they went up there and they did this fucking rap.
Okay.
And they went up there and they stuck their teeth out like they had buck teeth.
And then they put,
you know,
those glasses that you can put on those joke ones that make your eyes look
Asian.
They had though they're Asian and yet they still put those on.
And then the other guy had on,
uh,
of fake gold chain with a fucking fortune cookie hanging off the thick.
So I'm sitting there looking at it before they're going up going,
oh man,
this isn't going to fly.
This isn't going to fly with this fucking crowd.
This is basically,
uh,
what do you call that shit?
What did,
what was that shit back in the day in old time,
Hollywood,
it was almost like Asian black face.
Like what they were doing was fucking,
was ridiculous.
I was thinking that black people watching it,
we're going to be like,
just all the shit that they've been through.
We look at and be like,
what the,
why are they these fucking,
why are they selling out their own fucking race?
This is horrific.
This is fucking horrific.
And they didn't,
that act went up there and they fucking destroyed and everybody laughed their
balls off.
They thought the fortune cookie thing was fucking hilarious.
And I was just like,
yeah,
that people,
I don't know.
Maybe it's cause they're shitting on their own race.
What the fuck you supposed to do?
I don't know.
I just found that shit fascinating.
So what does that pertain to?
What the fuck?
I just said,
I don't know if it's cold medicines kicking in.
Let me finish this.
So anyways,
this is basically what this guy does.
He says,
uh,
J uh,
just to clarify the deputy.
Okay.
Now this game started because I hate watching the news and no matter what I'm
watching sports center,
usually my wife will want to change it and I'm so naturally being the asshole
that I am.
I had to figure out a way to ruin it for,
um,
so what I do is turn away from the news whenever they begin,
begin explaining the crimes are events of the day based on the description of
the crime or event and how it was committed or performed.
I yell either beaner black guy or crazy ass cracker.
Do that.
And she sounds like a fun fucking game.
Well,
I wouldn't say crazy ass cracker.
I would just say fucking white dude.
Um,
example news report says what I say.
Beaner no,
I wouldn't.
That's one of the worst ones ever.
Beaner it's got no ring.
It's got no flow.
That must've been a bad day with white people.
You know,
usually we're a lot more creative than that.
Named me after a fucking vegetable.
Is it a vegetable?
Is it a fruit?
What the fuck is it?
I know.
Anyways,
let's plow head example news report.
It says a man was stabbed and I yell out beaner I know it's a beaner because we
Mexicans can't afford guns and still pay for our legal extended family members.
We have living with us and our two bedroom house.
If the news report says a drive by shooting,
I yell Black Guy,
come on.
Do I really have to explain the reason behind that one?
And of course if I hear the suspect had body parts of his victims in the
refrigerator,
fucking crazy ass cracker.
It's because of this game that my wife has stopped watching the news altogether
and I now have peace and quiet to enjoy my top plays of the day.
Fixed on sports center.
Well good for you.
Good for you.
And I'll see that's something I don't,
I don't think that that's racist because what,
you don't have any hatred towards any of those groups.
What you're doing is you're actually
okay.
You don't want to watch the news.
It's fucking depressing.
You want to watch sports and then she puts on a double punch of depressing shit.
And what are you going to do sit there and get depressed?
Or are you going to fucking entertain yourself so you turn it into a fucking
game?
It's actually a a,
you know,
I'm not offended by it.
I think that's fucking funny and there's a lot of truth to it.
Okay.
Um,
oh,
here's a guy responding to,
they did with double.
Is that racist?
Um,
anyways,
so yeah.
Indians aren't big white people fans because the British controlled their
country for hundreds of years.
See that once again.
See,
we all can make ignorant statements.
So then you should hate the English.
Why do you hate all white people?
See that we're all just as dumb.
Oh God damn it.
This is,
this is,
this is enjoyable.
All right.
It's plow ahead here.
Something.
I remember reading about this.
I'm going to give you a vague description of what I remember.
This is classic for my podcast cause nobody knows what the fuck they're talking
about.
See this,
this is how we're all coming together.
Um,
yeah,
the British were fucking over the Indian people and Indian people did something.
They finally fucking snapped and they went off and they did something really
violent to,
uh,
some of the British people who were over there,
including women and children,
I believe.
And uh,
they went say,
you know,
we'll say one to 10 evil.
They went about five.
And then England said,
Oh yeah,
we'll fucking show you what ego evil is.
And then they came back and they went 15 and they were like,
fucking burning people alive.
They just went around just shooting everybody.
Um,
which is what you have to do when you fuck an occupy a country,
you have to commit fuck a genocide.
That's the only way,
which is why you shouldn't do it.
You know,
it's why you shouldn't invade another country because they ain't fucking
leaving.
Fuck it.
Leave and so on.
I don't know what the fuck.
You know what this is like,
that's part of a whole nother big district,
a discussion.
I shouldn't even a fucking brought it up,
but the only occupation I've ever seen that ever fucking work was in this
country.
And the reason why it worked was because we weren't leaving and we fucking
committed genocide,
that story.
And I'm not for that on any fucking level,
which is why when I look around the world and I see certain people in certain
areas,
I'm not surprised with what the fuck's going down.
Cause that's what always goes down.
So what always fucking goes down.
It's fucking the,
I dunno,
it's fucking,
it's evil.
No.
Come
on.
Speaking of which,
you know,
if you guys realize that right now,
Brett Farve
is getting sued,
sort of the shit,
this is how fucked up the world is right now.
Brett Farve is getting sued
okay.
By the,
uh,
by two Massoud.
Okay.
Because he tried to get,
uh,
some sort of sexual favors afterwards and they're,
they're,
they're suing for that.
Okay.
Do you understand that?
Let me say that just one more time.
Brett Farve is getting sued by a Mizzou tumor.
Susis is that how you said my sue says,
um,
mousses um,
tomosynthesis for asking basically to,
to,
uh,
you know,
to bang them at the end of it,
they're suing him.
Can you fucking believe that?
I just,
it's just fucking bus that will,
you know what that's like?
That's like me showing a comedy club because I got heckled.
It comes with the job.
There was not any machine,
any female must Zeus out there that listens to this podcast.
Are you honestly going to tell me that?
That you've been rubbing guys bags and their legs and the chest and all that and
you've,
no one has ever asked you for a fucking hand job at the end of it,
it fucking comes the territory.
That's like being a cop.
And so when the city,
cause you got shot at all,
right?
You fucking put hot oil all over a guy's body and you rub everything but their
dick.
I mean,
give me a fucking break.
You goddamn Cock teases.
Yeah.
People are going to ask you to rub one out.
Okay?
And if you had a shred of fucking decent,
so you'd do what?
You complete the God damn job.
All right,
because you sign says full body massage.
last I saw my dick is still part of my body.
All right.
You know what,
they'll,
you don't have a Susan's I liked it.
I liked the fucking quarterback who can't get it done,
you know,
just always comes up a little bit short.
They should fucking interview them afterwards.
So,
you know,
like what happened in there.
Uh,
you know,
I just didn't,
just didn't get it done.
You know,
it was like right there,
all I do is just reach out,
grab it.
And I just,
uh,
you know,
we didn't want,
we didn't want it as much as they wanted it.
Um,
that's just like,
just,
that's such a classic,
uh,
piggyback lawsuit.
It's like once that first stupid whore,
um,
you know,
gave Brett Farve Shit.
This is very interesting that I've noticed about horse.
Once one comes out of the woodwork,
then all of a sudden 20 come out of the woodwork,
you know,
and then they always try to paint it as well.
We would too scared.
We were scared.
Fuck you.
You were,
you trying to make money and you're trying to build on the momentum of the other
case.
That's the female version of pulling a train on somebody.
You know,
the guy version is,
you know,
you and 80 of friends,
bang the same girl.
The female version is,
you know,
you're a fucking whore and you're just waiting for a whore to sue a guy that you
fucking banked and then you fucking,
you,
you draft in right behind their lawsuit.
Okay?
You know some of those myths date,
they'll actually come to your house and give you a full body rubbed down with
oil.
Okay?
And then have the fucking nerve to get upset that you tried to get a hand job at
the end of it.
You know,
give me a fucking break.
Why don't you fucking Mizuho's broads man the fuck up it start rubbing one out.
Is it that God damn hard,
no pun intended?
Is it that fucking difficult
to just fucking,
you know,
it's like your revenue motorcycle.
That's it.
That's all you gotta do.
Up and down,
up and down with that dead fucking oily in and out.
You want that house on the hill,
sweetheart?
There's a price to pay.
All right?
Now when a quarterback who owns every fucking record,
good and bad in the Goddamn universe,
asked you to rub one out.
God Damn it.
You fucking rub one out.
Well,
maybe you don't blog in this business,
sister.
That's right.
Stare at your fucking manicured toes,
pedicure,
whatever the fuck
you supposed to say.
[inaudible].